Oh pink she's a wonderful person well
she's been through hell they put this
young woman through hell what she's had
to pay for legal fees and everything
else I let everybody testify I wanted to
be totally open because I knew there was
nothing there there was nothing there
nothing at all president Trump
vehemently defending former White House
comms director hope Hicks just a short
time ago the longtime Trump employee and
confidant of the first senior
administration official mentioned in the
Muller report to testify before Congress
well but as expected the Democrats on
the House Judiciary Committee didn't get
a lot of answers from her which of
course they claim is a conspiracy by the
president we should note Hicks is now
executive VP and chief of communications
for Fox Corporation joining me now Alan
Dershowitz former law professor emeritus
he also wrote a foreword to the
published version of the Muller report
Alan some dem say that heck's refusal to
answer questions pushes them further
down the path towards impeachment what
say you
mm hmm well first just one brief remark
about your prior segment anybody who
ever compares what's going on in our
southern border - never again our
concentration camps is encouraging
Holocaust denial because what they're
saying is if all that happened to the
Jews in Nazi Germany and Poland is
what's happening in the southern border
then there were no death camps there
were no killing squads there was no
final solution so shame on them for
being Holocaust deniers now as far as
the current issue is concerned look all
three branches of government have
privileged you can't call a law clerk
from the Supreme Court and ask the law
clerk what did you discuss with the
Justice imagine if they try to call
legislative assistants of senators or
congressmen the same congressmen who are
demanding that she speak would be up in
arms each branch of the government has a
form of executive privilege and the
president's perfectly entitled to invoke
executive privilege if they think it
goes too far let him take it to the
courts let the courts decide but the
danger is that you can diminish
executive privilege and legislative
privilege and judicial privilege not
only for this administration but for
future administrations and that would
have a big structural impact on
government announced civil liberties
Congressman Cicilline was on another
Network tonight and he's basically
saying look this is ridiculous Trump's
not a monarch that's a real
constitutional argument let's watch we
don't have a king there's no such thing
as absolute immunity there she didn't
invoke any privilege they just use this
made-up claim that they don't have to
answer any questions which will be
rejected again by a court the debate is
contiguous go ahead yeah these
congressmen always argue that president
is not above the law and then they put
themselves above the law they try to get
people to answer questions that are not
subject appropriately to being asked
they want to impeach without the
criteria for impeachment being satisfied
Congress is not above the law the
president acts within article 2 of the
Constitution that's not above the law
you know congressmen and Senators can't
be prosecuted for what they say on the
floor of Congress that doesn't mean
they're above the law
that is the law but there are different
laws regulating presidents congressmen
and members of the judiciary they all
have forms of immunity that doesn't put
them above the law that's what the law
provides if you don't like it change the
law well they say it's look there's no
absolute immunity from testimony there's
no absolute executive privilege but
conversations behind closed doors with
the President of the United States I
think going back to the Clinton
administration the OLC opinion on this
Saul Eisenberg tweeted this earlier
tonight it's pretty clear that this kind
of this is classic executive privilege
information the classic well first it is
number one number two presidents often
invoke executive privilege in close
cases and leave it to the courts that's
what our system of checks and balances
is about Congress seeks the information
the president says no the courts decide
the system works when that happens and I
know of no president who has ever
refused to accept the rulings of the
court when the court said to Nixon turn
over the tapes he did when the courts
told Clinton he had to make certain
provisions he did and there's no
evidence that Trump wouldn't do the same
thing so Congress has the right to power
to go to the courts but they shouldn't
be complaining
about the invocation of privilege
because they would be doing it
themselves if their staff members were
being called by prosecutors to testify
yeah bingo Alan it's great to talk to
you and great to hear your thoughts